اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
ضخ مود تضارب جديد بين السقوط والصمود
روسيا تعلن السيطره على المدينه والسلطات
الاوكرانيه تنفي
[تصفيق]
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتحم نابلس وتقتل
الفلسطينيين وتعتقل اثنين واسرائيل تتاهب
على جبهه الحدود الشماليه
ولمواجهه تهديدات كوريا الشماليه تحت
الماء منورات بحريه بين امريكا واليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه
[موسيقى]
قبل يوم من محاكمته ترامب يتصدر استطلاعات
الراي داخل الحزب الجمهوري لتولي رئاسه
امريكا في عام 2024
صباح الخير في حرب اوكرانيا مشاهدينا عادت
الانظار تتركز على بخ موت ومن جديد تضاربت
الانباء حول سقوطها وصمودها مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه اعلنت سيطرتها على مبنى بلديه
بخموت شرق اوكرانيا ما يعني انها سيطرت
على المدينه من وجهه نظر قانونيه ولوح
قائد فاجنر يبغيني بعلم الروسي من امام
مبنى البلديه كما نشاهد في هذا الفيديو
قائلا انه تمت السيطره على باخ مود وان
القوات الاوكرانيه متمركزه في المناطق
الغربيه
اليوم الثاني من ابريل بالتحديد الساعه
الحاديه عشره مساء خلفي مبنى اداره مدينه
بخموت هذا هو العلم الروسي كتب عليه
تحديدا للذكرى الطيبه لقد اخذنا مخمود من
وجهه نظر قانونيه قاده وحدات القوات
الروسيه الذين تولوا اداره المدينه والحيه
المركزيه باكمله سيرفعون الاعلام العدو ظل
في الاحياء الغربيه
في المقابل اكد الجيش الاوكراني انه ما
زال يسيطر على بخموت الواقعه شرقي
اوكرانيا وقالت هيئه الاركان العامه
الاوكرانيه ان روسيا لم توقف هجماتها على
بخموت وان المدافعين الاوكرانيين يسيطرون
على المدينه وصدوا الكثير من الهجمات
بخموت مشاهدينا شهدت في الاشهر الاخيره
معارك عنيفه القوات الروسيه تقدمت باتجاه
شمال المدينه وجنوبها قاطع طريق الامدادات
الاوكرانيه ومن ثم سيطرت على الجزء الشرقي
منها قبل نحو اسبوعين في 20 مارس الماضي
تحديدا اعلنت فاجنر سيطرتها على سبعين في
المئه من بخ موت حينها اقر الاوكرانيون
بصعوبه الوضع لكنهم نفو سيطره الروس على
المدينه كيف ترى ان معركه باخموت تهدف
بالتحديد الى احتواء القوات الروسيه على
كامل الجبهه الشرقيه رغم ان محللين
يعتبرون ان اهميه المدينه على الصعيد
الاستراتيجي محدوده
[تصفيق]
معنى من كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل
اهلا بك معنا حذيفه لنتحدث بدايه عن
التضارب في الاقوال حول باخموت يعني
الجانب الروسي وفاكنر تحديدا يعلنون
سيطرتهم على المدينه ورفع العلم الروسي
على مبنى البلديه اما الجانب الاوكراني
ينفي ذلك ونضيف اليه احاديث زيلينسكي عن
قلقه عن الاسبوع القادم من يعني نقطه
حاسمه ونقطه تحول ستكون الاسبوع الماضي
ربما تتركز حول بخموت حدثنا اكثر عنها
حذيفه
صباح الخير فاطمه في الحقيقه الرئيس
فلاديمير زيلينسكي تحدث في الرساله
المسائيه بالامس حول باخمه بدا بالشكر
للجنود الاوكرانيين الذين يقاتلون في ظروف
صعبه كما قال وافاد الرئيسكي قال ان الوضع
ساخن جدا في منطقه باخموت الوضع صعب جدا
بالنسبه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه لذلك
هو يشكر القوات التي ما زالت تدافع عن هذه
المدينه وهذه الرساله المسائيه بالامس
اليوم ان ميلر نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني ايضا تحدثت عن الوضع في باقمت
وقالت ان الوضع صعب بشكل استثنائي في
مدينه باقمت قالت ان على القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ان تدافع عن المدينه في ظروف
صعبه جدا واستثنائيه ايضا قالت ان الجيش
الاوكراني يدرس جميع الظروف
ويعني يجهز لجميع السيناريوهات وهذه طبعا
اعتبرت من قبل المراقبين انها اشاره الى
قد تكون هنالك دراسه لوضع الانسحاب من
مدينه اباخ موت لكنهم يؤكدون انهم ما
زالوا يسيطرون على المدينه كذلك قائد جهاز
الامن والمخابرات الجائزه جهاز الامن
الاوكراني قال ان القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ما زالت تقاتل في المدينه ولا
صحه للانباء التي تتوارث حول السيطره
الكامله للقوات الروسيه عن المدينه هذا هو
الجانب الرسمي ولكن بشكل غير رسمي ايضا
هنالك بعض قنوات التيليجرام وتعلمين ان
القنوات التيليجرام هي مشهوره ومنتشره في
شرق اوروبا بشكل عام وفي اوكرانيا وروسيا
كذلك الجنود الاوكرانيين الذين يقاتلون في
باخموت ارسلوا عده رسائل من هناك وقالوا
ان القوات الروسيه استطاعت بالامس ان تحقق
تقدما في بعض الاحياء داخل مدينه باقمه
ولكن بعد عصر الامس استطاعت القوات
الاوكرانيه ان تعود وتسترد هذه المواقع
داخل المدينه الوضع من الجهه الجنوبيه
هنالك تقدم من قبل القوات الروسيه كذلك من
الجهه يعني شمال غرب المدينه هنالك محاوله
لاكمال عمليه الحصار للمدينه ولكن هذه هذا
التقدم لا يحقق نجاح بحسب وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه والقتال الشرس في هذه المنطقه
تحدثت قبل قليل فاطمه عن الاسبوع القادم
وما اشار اليه الرئيسكي بالفعل الرئيسي
يقول ان الاسبوع القادم سيكون حاسما
للمعركه بشكل عام وليس فقط في اباك يقول
انه سيكون اسبوع صعب جدا سيحدد مسير
المعركه طبعا تعلمين ان عمليه ايصال
الامدادات الان فيها تعقيد كبير الان الجو
بدا في يعني بشكل عام في الشرق تحديدا
الجو يتغير الان هنالك ارتفاع في درجه
الحراره
الثلوج تذوب بعد ذلك سيكون هنالك ثبات
للارض وهذه الفتره التي ينتظرها الجميع
سوى الاوكرانيون او الروس للتقدم وتحقيق
مكاسب على ارض المعركه بعد ان تستقر الارض
وتستطيع الاليات والمدرعات والاسلحه في
التقدم والهجوم واضح شكرا لك من كيف مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل
قال السفير الروسي اللدى
ان بلاده ستنقل اسلحتها النوويه التكتيكيه
الى القرب من الحدود الغربيه لبيلاروسيا
وهو ما سيجعلها على عتاب دول اعضاء في حلف
شمال الاطلسي ولم يحدد اجريزي لوف مكان
وضع الاسلحه لكنه اكد ان منشاه التخزين
الخاصه بها ستكتمل بحلول يوليو او الاول
من يوليو بناء على طلب الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين وستنتقل بعد ذلك الاسلحه
الى بلا روسيا هذا وقد اعرب مسبقا او اعرب
الولايات المتحده وحلفاء اخرون لاوكرانيا
عن قلقهم اذا احتماليه ارسال روسيا
الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه الى روسيا
البيضاء وقال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان
ذلك الامر مثير للقلق
وقع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين مرسوما
بشان انشاء صندوق حكومي لدعم المحاربين في
الخطوط الاماميه في اوكرانيا تحت اسم
المدافعون عن الوطن وذكرت وثيقه نشرها
موقع رينوفيس لان الهدف من القانون ضمان
حياه كريمه وعمل نشط من الجنود والضباط
المشاركين في العمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا وكان قد اعلنت الرئاسه البولنديه
مشاهدين ان الرئيس الاوكراني
سيزور وارسو يوم الاربعاء المقبل في
الخامس من ابريل وظيفه انه سيلتقي
باللاجئين في ساحه قلعه العاصمه ومن جهته
اعلن مسؤول السياسه الدوليه في مكتب
الرئيس البولندي اعلن ان بلاده سلمت اربع
مقاتلات
ما يمثل اول عمليه تسليم من قبل دوله عضو
في حلف شمال الاطلسي
نفت الرياسه الاوكرانيه مشاهدينا الضلوع
في تفجير احد المقاهي في سنه بطرز الذي
قتل فيه مدون عسكري روسي وكانت السلطات
الروسيه قد اعلنت في وقت سابق ان التفجير
استهدف المراسل الحربي التابع لفاغنر
فلادلين تتارسكي وخلف التفجير ايضا اكثر
من 30 مصابا بينهم عشره اشخاص في حاله
حرجه
مراسلون عسكري روسي ومدون معروف فقد حياته
في تفجير احد المقاهي في مدينه سامبروسبرج
الروسيه حسب وزاره الداخليه لم تتبنى حتى
الان اي جهه مسؤوليه الانفجار كما لم تقدم
السلطات اي تفاصيل عما قالت ان سببه هو
قنبله كانت بحوزه احد رواد المقهى لكن
مقاطع ما قبل لحظات من التفجير اظهرت
تتاسكي وهو يحمل تمثالا صغيرا قدم له من
احد رواد المقهى
يبدو بانها هي تلك القنبله التي تسببت
بالحادثه بحسب وسائل اعلام روسيه
مصدر في قوات الامن لوكاله تاسك قال بان
قوه العبوه الناسفه تجاوزت 200 جرام من
ماده تي ان تي وبحسب منظم الحدث داخل
المقهى فان الاجراءات الامنيه الضعيفه
سمحت بوقوع التفجير لكن السر يكمن في
خفايا المقهى المتضرر من التفجير فهو مقهى
تعود ملكيته لقائد مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه
الروسيه حسب اعلام روسي
والابرز شخصيه الصحفي المستهدف فمقاطع
فيديو سابقه للمراسل الحربي المقتول يظهر
فيها وهو يردد عبارات تحريضيه
تشير الى انه مؤيد للعمليه العسكريه
الروسيه الا انه ينتقد استراتيجيه
الجنرالات في وزاره الدفاع كما يفعل قائده
مؤسس فاجنر
سنهزم الجميع وسنقتل الجميع وسنسلب كل من
يحتاج الى السرقه وسيكون كل شيء كما نحب
يعد ثانيه اهم حادثه بعد سابقه لها العام
الماضي اودت بحياه داريا دوجينا ابنه
الكسندر دوجن الفيلسوف الروسي المقرب من
الرئيس بوتين في انفجار سياره يشتبه بانها
كانت ملغمه روان حمزه العربيه
واستمرون معكم بعد الفاصل ونتابع
ولكن قبل الخروج الى هذا الفاصل المشاهدين
نشير الى هذا العاجل امامكم على الشاشه
حيث تقول السلطات الروسيه بانها اعتقلت
متهمه بقتل مدون عسكري روسي في هذا المدون
الذي كان في مقهى
بها كانت تتواجد معه في ذات المقهى
الان فاصل ونعود نتابع لقاءات ثنائيه في
موسكو تسبق اجتماعا رباعيا يبحث تطبيع
العلاقات بين تركيا وسوريا
حياكم الله من جديد نعود الى او نبدا من
اسرائيل حيث رفعت حاله التاهب امنيا
وعسكريا على الحدود الشماليه بشقيها
السوري واللبناني وذلك غدا اسقاط مسيره
يعتقد بانها ايرانيه فوق منطقه الحوله
شمال طبريا في الجليل وكان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اجمع حطام المسيره ليلا واوضح
انها كانت تعقب دائم من مقاتلتين ومروحيه
عسكريه وكان قد كشف الجيش الاسرائيلي
الطريقه التي استخدمها لاسقاط المسيره
القادمه من سوريا الليله الماضيه وبحسب ما
نقلته صحيفه دعوت احرنوت فان المسيره لم
تسقط بفعل صاروخ او بالنيران وانما بوسائل
ناعمه وفق وصف الصحيفه التي قالت ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اسقط المسيره التي رجح ان تكون
ايرانيه الصنع اسقطها بواسطه الحرب
الالكترونيه اذ يتم ارسال اشارات عن بعد
تعطل حركه الطائره وتتسبب في سقوطها وهي
طريقه دابت اسرائيل على استخدامها خلال
العامين الماضيين لاسقاط طائرات من دون
طيار على حدود كل من لبنان وغزه من
الجولان حول ذلك ينضم الينا مدير مكتب
العربيه في فلسطين زياد حلبي اهلا بك معنا
زياد اذا ما التفاصيل لديك
هذا صحيح ما حدث كان دراماتيكيا لجهه
التطور اسرائيل فعليا جمعت حطام هذه
الطائره ولهذا استخدمت الحرب الالكترونيه
لاسقاطها وليس صاروخا من المقاتلات التي
واكبتها بعمق 30 كيلومترا تقريبا داخل
الاجواء الاسرائيلية كي تتعرف على هويه
هذه
الطائره
وطبعا هي ترجح بان تكون تابعه
لايران ذلك اعقب جاء بعد اقل من يوم من
استهداف اسرائيل لمطار الضبعه العسكري في
حمص ومطار التيفور حيث مخازن اسلحه او
مخازن مسيرات ايرانيه معده لحزب الله
عمليا هذه الغارات
بحسب بعض المصادر جاءت ردا على عمليه حزب
الله في مجده العمليه الاخيره التي كان
فيها عمليات
ومحاوله تفجير سياره داخل
الجليل عمليا
وجاءت بعد سلسله غارات يعني ثلاثه غارات
على الاقل في خلال اربعه ايام لهذا هناك
الان حال تاهب على هذه الجبهه هنا في
الجولان المحتل وكذا ايضا في
حدود مع لبنان يعني نحن منذ ساعتين هنا
تقريبا
استطعنا ان نرى في بعض الاحيان مقاتلات
اسرائيليه تحلق وبطبيعه الحال هناك دبابات
ايضا منتشره في مواقع متقدمه عمليا
بسبب هذا التاهب الحاصل يمكن بعد قليل
ربما ان نريكم ذلك على الهواء مباشره احدى
الدبابات الاسرائيليه الموجوده بالقرب من
هذه المنطقه التي نحن فيها شكرا لك من
الجولان مدير مكتب العربيه زياد حلبي
سنتابع معك التط ورات بكل تاكيد
وبموازاه التاهب الاسرائيلي على الحدود
الشماليه اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
مقتل شاب بين فلسطينيين برصاص القوات
الاسرائيليه وذلك خلال اقتحامهما حي
المخفيه في نابلس في الضفه الغربيه وافاد
مراسل العربيه بوقوع اشتباكات واطلاق نار
اطلاق قوه اسرائيليه الحين كما اعتقلت
القوات الاسرائيليه شابين خلال مداهمه احد
المباني في نابلس بذريعه الاشتباه في
ضلوعهما بعمليه اطلاق النار الاخيره في
حواره
[موسيقى]
من رام الله معنا مراسل العربيه خالد
القاسم اهلا بك معنا خالد اذن اشتباكات
واقتحامات للقوات الاسرائيليه في نابلس
كيف هي الاوضاع الان بعد اعتقال المطلوبين
يعني الاوضاع الان هادئه ولكن يعم الحداد
الشامل جميع مرافق الحياه في مدينه نابلس
على اثر سقوطي فلسطينيه برصاص الجيش
الاسرائيلي فجراها او صباح هذا اليوم
البيان الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بانه
بان قوات من الجيش
والمستعربين
التابعه لحرس الحدود والمخابرات
الاسرائيليه تلقت معلومات
تفيد
بالاشتباه بان اثنين من مدينه نابلس ساعده
منفذ عمليه حواره في الخامس والعشرين من
الشهر الماضي والتي
اصيب خلالها ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين
بالرصاص واثناء محاوله اعتقال هذين
الفلسطينيين جرت اشتباكات مسلحه في حي
المخفيه وشارع تلو حي القصبه في البلده
القديمه بم دينه نابلس ادت الى مقتل
فلسطينيين واعتقال من تقول اسرائيلي
اسرائيل بانهما ساعد منفذ عمليه حواره
الاسبوع الماضي طيب بعد عمليه الاعتقال
خالد هل تم تعليم المنازل لهدمها كما يعني
اعتدنا ان نرى
لا تعليم المنازل لهدمها واخذ قياسات
المنازل لهدمها تعلن عنها اسرائيل عندما
يكون هناك منفذ عمليه غالبا يكون نتيجتها
مقتل اسرائيليين تعاقب اسرائيل
اهالي منفذي هذه العمليات بهدم منازلهم
لكن فجر هذا اليوم لم يكن هناك اي تعليم
او هدم لمنازل فلسطينيين في مدينه نابلس
واضح شكرا لك من رام الله مراسل العربيه
خالد القاسم
الى العاصمه الروسيه موسكو حيث تنعقد
اليوم لقاءات ثنائيه استعدادا لاجتماعا
رباعيا سيعقد سيعقد غدا الثلاثاء حول
مساعي تطبيع العلاقات بين انقره ودمشق
اللقاءات تجري على مستوى نواب ووزراء
خارجيه كل من روسيا وايران سوريا وتركيا
وقال نائب وزير الخارجيه السوري ايمن
سوسان الوفد السوري سيركز في الاجتماع
بالتحديد على انهاء التواجد العسكري
التركي على الاراضي السوريه ومكافحه
الارهاب وعدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
السوريه على حد قوله مستمرون معكم ونتابع
مع التقارب الاوروبيه الصينيه ماكرون
يتوجهان الى بكينه اربعاء
مود تضارب جديد بين السقوط والصمود روسيا
تعلن السيطره على المدينه والسلطات
الاوكرانيه في
[تصفيق]
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتحم نابلس وتقتل
الفلسطينيين وتعتقل اثنين واسرائيل تتاهب
على جبهه الحدود الشماليه
لمواجهه تهديدات كوريا الشماليه تحت الماء
مناورات بحريه بين امريكا واليابان وكوريا
الجنوبيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قبل يوم من محاكمته ترامب يتصدر استطلاعات
الراي داخل الحزب الجمهوري لتولي رئاسه
امريكا لعام 2024
حياكم الله من جديد اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه مشاهدينا ان الرئيس الفرنسي
ايمانويل ماكرون سيقوم بزياره الى بكين
الاربعاء المقبل تمتد الى ثلاثه ايام حيث
يلتقي نظيره الصيني شيجي بنك وعددا من
المسؤولين هذا من المقرر ان يعقد ماكرون
اجتماعا غدا مع رئيسه المفوضه الاوروبيه
ارسل فوندر لاين قبل توجههما سويا الى
الصين
بدات الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان مناورات بحريه مشتركه اليوم هي
الاولى منذ سبع سنوات تشمل تدريبات البحث
والانقاذ المضاده للغواصات لمده يومين
وذلك بمشاركه حامله الطائرات يو اس اس
نيمت الامريكيه في المياه الدوليه جنوب
جزيره جيجو الجنوبيه وذلك وفق ما اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع او دفاع الكوريه الجنوبيه
الوزاره اوضحت ايضا ان التدريبات تاتي
لتعزيز قدرات الاستجابه ضد التهديدات
لكوريا الشماليه تحت الماء بما في ذلك
الصواريخ الباليستيه التي تطلق من
الغواصات
حقق زعيم الائتلاف الوطني الفنلندي
حقق الفوز في الانتخابات التشريعيه في
هلسكني خلفا لرئيسه الوزراء المنتهيه
ولايتها الاجتماعيه الديمقراطيه سنه
البدء في مفاوضات لتشكيل حكومه اما رئيسه
الوزراء سانا مارين فاعترفت به هزيمتها في
الانتخابات وحلت في المرتبه الثالثه بعد
حزبين الائتلاف الوطني واليميني المتطرف
الى موطنيغرو حيث حقق المرشح ياكوب
ميلاتوبيتش الفوز في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
بفارق كبير عن منافسه ميلودانوفيتش وذلك
رغما عن حداثته النسبيه في السياسه وافادت
تقديرات منظمه متخصصه في رصد عمليات
الاقتراع افادت ان ميلاتوفيتش حاز في
الدوره الثانيه من الانتخابات على نحو 60%
من الاصوات مقابل اربعين في المئه لمنافسه
ونفى رئيس كوسوفو السابق هاشم تاجي نف
الموجهه امام محكمه خاصه في لاهاي
بارتكابي جرائم حرب وجرائم ضد الانسانيه
كذلك خلال حرب الاستقلال بين العامين 98 و
99 واكد تاجي المحاربه السابق في جيش
تحرير كوسوفو اكد انه غير مذنب على
الاطلاق وقد انتخب تاجي او انتخب رئيسا
لكوسوفو في عام 2016 لكنه استقال بعدما
وجهت اليه التهم
الى عاشق الاضواء ومحبوب الجمهوريين انه
الرئيس السابق للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الذي اثبت انه ومهما وجهت له اتهامات فانه
يبقى الافضل على الاقل في عين حسبه بل انه
المرشح الاكثر تفضيلا بين الجمهوريين
لتولي منصب رئاسه امريكا لعام 2020
ففي استطلاع راي اجرته
شمل اكثر من الف شخص في هذا الاستطلاع من
مؤيدي الحزب الجمهوري اكتسحت شامب هذه
الاستطلاعات بين الجمهوريين حيث اظهرت
النتيجه ان 52 من المستطلعين يؤيدون ترامب
ومستعدون لترشيحه العام المقبل يليه
المنافس الاقوى وهو حاكم فلوريدارون
ديسانتيز بالنسبه دعم بلغت 21% واظهر
استطلاع راي اخر ليغاف حول قرار هيئه
المحلفين توجيه اكثر من 30 تهمه لترامب
43% يعتبرون قرار هيئه المحلفين مدفوعا
بتحفيز سياسي بينما اعتبر 42% ان هذا
القرار نابع من رغبتهم في محاسبه ترامب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
رغم اتهامهم من قبل محكمه في نيويورك ورود
اسمه في قضايا اخرى
الا ان 37 نائبا جمهوريا اعلنوا مساندتهم
[موسيقى]
لا يزال المرشح المفضل لدى الحزب الجمهوري
لانتخابات 2024
الاسباب تتلخص في ثلاث نقاط
تقدم ترامب في استطلاعات الراي في
الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوري لعام
2024 خلال الشهر الماضي
يعتقد معظم الجمهوريين ان جميع الملاحقات
القضائيه المتعلقه بالتروم ذات دوافع
سياسيه
غالبيه مؤيدي ترامب لا يصورهم القلق بشان
قدرته على خوض الانتخابات العامه
وبينما ينتظر ملايين الامريكيين مثله امام
محكمه نيويورك طلبت من مؤيديها التبرع
لحمله اعاده انتخابه لعام 2020 وذلك في
بيان نشر على موقع
قبل يومين فقط من الموعد المتوقع لتقديمه
الى المحاكمه ترامب الذي لا يزال الغموض
حيث يحيطه بالتهم التي ستوجه اليه في
المحاكمه غدا الثلاثاء قال ان انتخابات
عام 2020 مزوره ومسروقه مشددا على
استعادتها في الانتخاب الرئاسات او
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله لعام 2020
مشيرا ايضا الى ان الهجمات التي استهدفته
لم يشهدها اي رئيس اخر في تاريخ امريكا
قبل يومين من تقديمه للمحاكمه ما زال بعض
الغموض يلف قضيه الرئيس الامريكي دونالد
ترامب وما سيواجهه خلال المحاكمه وفيما
وصلت اليه القضيه فهناك خمس ملاحظات لما
يتهم به ترامب وما قد يواجهه اولها فان
لائحه ستبقى سريه حتى يمثل تشاب امام
المحكمه ما لم يطلب المدعي العام الكشف
عنها لا تفاصيل واضحه عن طبيعه الاتهام
الذي سيواجهه لكن مصادر مطلعه رجحت ان
تتضمن تهما جنائيه التحقيق في السابق كان
يركز على دفع 130 الف دولار قبل
الانتخابات الرئاسيه باسابيع شراء الصمت
بالاموال يعتبر قضيه قانونيه لكن المخاوف
تدور حول ان تتضمن التهم تزوير سجلات
تجاريه ولاثبات تورط ترامب سيحتاج المدعون
اثبات انه كان متورطا شخصيا فيما اتهموه
به
اعترف بالدفع لدانه ومحامه فسر الامر بانه
لحمايه زواجه لكنهم يخشون ان يسعى المدعي
العام للحصول على تهم جنائيه من خلال
تاكيد على ان المدفوعات تنتهك قوانين
الحمله الانتخابيه بطريقه ما تقول اخر
المعلومات ان رئيس السابق يريد ان يتم
تقييد يديه عند ظهور امام المحكمه معتقدا
انه سيكون استعراضا مهيبا للقوه قوه لا
يريد حتى حاكم ولايه فلوريدا التورته في
مواجهتها
خرجت نحو 25 او 25 عربه قطار عن مسارها في
ولايه مونتانا الامريكيه على طول نهر
كلورك وذكرت السلطات ان رجال الاطفاء
وممثلي الشركه المشغله للقطار اكدوا ان
القطار لم يكن يحمل اي مواد خطره واضافت
السلطات ان التحقيق جاري لتحديد سبب
انحراف عربات القطار عن المسار
غير قوانين شاره التحقق الزرقاء التويتر
ونسف عدد موظفي الشركه الى النصف وبالطبع
لا يستغني عن سيل تغريداته للتعبير عن
رايه او فيما ينوي فعله في العصفور الازرق
تلك هي عاده الملياردير الامريكي الى
الماسك الذي لم يابه بصحيفه نيويورك تايمز
العريقه بل وسخر منها باشد العبارات
عبارات لاذعه وقوله انها غير مقروءه وفي
احدى تغريداته الساخره قلموس انه يعتبر
نيويورك تايمز منافقه بشكل لا يصدق لانها
عدوانيه للغايه بشان اجبار الجميع على
دافع او دفع اشتراكهم كل ذلك لان الصحيفه
اعلنت انها لن تدفع مقابل علامه التحقق
لصحفييها ليسحب ماسك علامه التحقق او
تويتر بلو منهم واشارت نيويورك تايمز الى
انه قد تكون هناك بعض الاستثناءات النادره
عندما تكون الشراب ضروريه لاغراض اعداد
التقارير اي ان ماسك بهذه الحاله وبشكل او
باخر يؤكد ان قضيه الثمانيه الدولارات لا
مفر منها يشهد سوق الاواني في موريتانيا
رواجا كبيرا خلال شهر رمضان المبارك حيث
تحرص العائلات على اقتناء اواني جديده
تماشيا مع ما تحتاجه الماده المائده
الرمضانيه مع تنوع الاطباق والماكولات من
اوان وادوات منزليه خصوصا في ظل الافطارات
العائليه
[موسيقى]
شهر رمضان اهم مواسم رواج السوق الاواني
المنزليه في موريتانيا ينتظره التجار طيله
العام وفي كل رمضان تكتمي السيدات
حاجياتهن المختلف الاواني سواء تلك
المخصصه للمشروبات او للوجبات الرمضانيه
المختلفه
الاواني التي اشتريتها في رمضان السابق لم
تعد صالحه وذلك بسبب تدني الجوده فرغم
انها تعرض على انها من الدرجه الاولى او
الثانيه فلا فرق كلها لا تدوم لعام كامل
يبدا الاخبال مبكرا على شراء الاواني
ومستلزمات المطبخ قبل رمضان باسابيع
ويستمر خلال ايام الشهر المبارك ومع كل
رمضان يستورد تجار الاواني منتجات جديده
من الخارج بهدف عرض بضائع مختلفه عن بضاعه
العام السابق تحقيقا لاستفاده اكبر من
الموسم
كل عام
في الجوده وفي التمارين اليوم
2500 ان شاء الله
يرجع الاقبال على شراء الاواني المنزليه
في رمضان الى العادات والتقاليد الغذائيه
في خلال هذا الشهر حيث تتنوع المعده
الموريتانيه ويضاف لها عديد الوجبات
والمشروبات التي لا تحوى خلال بقيه العام
بما تحوى به من اقبال واهتمام خلال شهر
رمضان ابراهيم مصطفى العربيه نواكشوط
من احياء الحجاز والشام الى خنادق الرصاص
والموت خلال الحرب العالميه الاولى يتناول
مسلسل سفر برلك ما ارتكبته الدوله
العثمانيه بحق اهل شبه الجزيره العربيه
والتجنيد الالزامي للشبان العرب دراما
اجتماعيه تاريخيه لا يغيب عنها الطابع
الرومانسي ضمن القصه اخر مشروع حضر له
المخرج الراحل حاتم علي قبيله وفاته وهو
من اخراج الليث حجو البطوله توزعت بين
نجوم من السعوديه سوريا لبنان والعالم
العربي المزيد في تقرير الدراما مع سهى
الوعل واعداد ايهم القاسم
[موسيقى]
انت عارف ايش يسمون دولتك في اوروبا الرجل
المريض
بكل الحين قاعد انتظره يموت
الكل مجتمع يبغى يسقط دوله الاسلام بعد
[موسيقى]
مرحبا
مؤلمه بعد مئه عام هذا هو مسلسل سفر
ابرليك اللي كان مفاجاه الموسم الدرامي
الرمضاني الضخمه عن كارثه التهجير الجماعي
القسري لطبقتها الدوله العثمانيه عام
1915 تجاه الالاف من الرجال والنساء
والاطفال من سكان المدينه المنوره حدث
تاريخي كان من المهم جدا للدراما ان
تتناولوا يوما هذا حدث له
قيمته التاريخيه وايضا قيمته الانسانيه
ويعتبر اليوم وكانه جريمه حرب لانه تم
تهجيرها هذه المدينه حتى قيل في كثير من
مصادر التاريخيه انه لم يبقى الا 41 شخص
من اهالي المدينه
يقتلون المدينه المنوره تم تهجيرا بالكامل
العمل يروي حكايه السعودي عبد الرحمن
المداني ورفاق دراسه الجامعيه في اسطنبول
السوري يحيى واللبنانيين فايز وفريد حيث
يخوض الاصدقاء الاربعه رحله الوعي السياسي
والانتقال من اروقه التحصيل العلمي الى
جبهات القتال مع الجيش العثماني اولا في
معارك البلقان على الحدود الروسيه ومن ثم
التمرد على ظلم السلطنه العثمانيه ووحشيه
ممارساتها انا فعلا حاسس ان انا في
اسطنبول يعني فعلا حسن في اسطنبول الابنيه
التفاصيل الديكورات المحلات اللبس المترو
العربيات الحنطور تفاصيل التفاصيل
التفاصيل جدا كلها موجوده وكلها موضوعه
بعنايه لدرجه انه فعليا الواحد فينا
بيصدقني اسطنبول كان كان شيء كثير كبير
لالنا
بالارز لما صورنا على حدود البلكان كان
كمان شي كتير حلو لانه عبد الرحمن مثلا
كثير كان بالنسبه له ثلج كثير كبير وكثير
بضحك كثير كان الجو حلو هناك وما حسينا
لحالنا يعني انه افترقنا هلا كتير اشتقنا
للسات هون كمان بس برا كان كمان كانت
مغامره لالنا انا وعبد الرحمن ويحيى
الجمهور والنقاد تفاعلوا مع العمل باهتمام
كبير هنا بعد التغريدات
[موسيقى]
اذا كان مكتوب على اهل ذي البلاد انهم
يحاربون
وهم واهلهم اولى في جهادهم ودمهم
الى العناوين
[موسيقى]
تضارب جديد بين السقوط والصمود روسيا تعلن
السيطره على المدينه والسلطات الاوكرانيه
تنفي
[تصفيق]
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتحم نابلس وتقتل
الفلسطينيين وتعتقل اثنين واسرائيل تتاهب
على جبهه الحدود الشماليه
لمواجهتي تهديدات كوريا الشماليه تحت
الماء مناورات بحريه بين امريكا واليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وقبل يوم من محاكمته ترامب يتصدر
استطلاعات الراي داخل الحزب الجمهوري
لتولي رئاسه امريكا لعام 2024
في امان الله
[موسيقى]